bonsoir et la respire merci d'être avec
nous quatrièmes élections législatives
en deux ans ça fait beaucoup quand même
une grande instabilité politique qui
règne en israël cette fois ci c'est la
dernière a peut-être peut-être pas le
problème de fond à vient effectivement
de la disparition à du parti qui a
souvent gouverné israël il ya pendant de
nombreuse dizaine d'années le parti
travailliste qui maintenant ne
représente plus que 5 % des sièges donc
la disparition de cette de ce parti qui
équilibrait entre droite et gauche qui
donnait donc une balance à a produit par
son implosion une grande dispersion des
voix
alors il faut savoir que effectivement
dans ce scrutin de liste
vous disposez de sièges à partir du
moment où votre liste a obtenu au moins
3,25 pour cent des sièges des voix en
trois vagues pour 25% des voix donc
directement vous avez par ce paramétrage
du scrutin un grand nombre de listes et
la coalition qui va diriger le pays ne
peut être construite qu'après le
résultat dans les urnes étant donné le
grand émiettement potentiel il n'est pas
possible de construire une coalition
avant le scrutin
alors à la fin de la journée le taux de
participation était de 51,20 nulle part
dont 51 8,5 pour cent soit 4 8 % en
moins par rapport à l'année dernière est
ce qui est une forme de lassitude de la
part des israéliens alors ça peut être
un facteur mais n'oublions pas non plus
la situation sanitaire a donc qui
n'encourage pas forcément aux
déplacements donc je crois que quatre
scrutins effectivement en deux ans c'est
beaucoup
il n'y a pas d'enjeu non plus à
l'intérieur
n'est ce pas 2
d'israël pour le moment il n'y a pas de
grands conflits il n'ya plus d'anti fada
il n'ya plat de cerfs-volants
incendiaires voilà un des lièges et l
apaisement à au moins d'être nature
militaire avec le hamas et à avec la
cisjordanie
donc vous avez des enjeux simplement
extérieur et qui sont moins prégnant
dans la situer dans la société
israélienne
il ya tout de même eu un tir de roquette
août à leurs intérêts ce soir depuis
gaza en direction d'israël c'est devenu
voilà coutumière évidemment ça ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui mais ça veut dire qu'à
une forme quand même de pression sur ces
élections de tensions ont pas vraiment
comme vous ne signez vous même donc ce
n'est pas une roquette qui va changer
vraiment le cours de ce vote
ah s'il y avait effectivement des
dizaines de requêtes et tous les jours
où il a honoré deux situations là ce
n'est un événement ce n'est pas une
situation et je crois que le le peuple
israélien dans la conjecture conjoncture
actuelle on regarde ce qui se passe
autour de lui et est donc là vous avez
des craintes vis-à-vis du hezbollah
libanais vous avez des craintes avec les
actions de l'iran et est donc la demande
d'un premier ministre fort d'un premier
ministre qui a fait ses preuves et sur
lequel bien tous les dossiers à qui lui
étaient reprochés le dossier 1000 2000
3000 4000 inconsciemment des affaires
d'un flux ans ou davantage qui aurait
obtenu est bien ne pèse plus rien
maintenant ce sont vraiment les
conditions extérieures qui ont la
primauté est ce que benyamin netanyahou
peut une nouvelle fois incarner cet
homme fort sachant il affiche un beau
succès sur sa campagne vaccinale un souk
au vide
oui c'est un homme fort comment votre
présentatrice eu tout à l'heure la
mentionner il le porte en lui même il a
une force naturelle
donc est ce ce que les israéliens je
lirai accepte bien volontiers ils ont
besoin d'un leader fort et et est
reconnu 1
lutte contre le coc vide a été un succès
relativement important donc cela va dans
le bon sens et cela peut l'aider mais il
faut pas oublier que dans le la knesset
dans le parlement qui vient de sortir
n'est ce pas le likoud ne représente que
36 sièges c'est à dire simplement 30%
des voix
donc une des faiblesses de sept de ces
collisions qui se sont succédé c'est que
le parti le plus fort
le parti leader et bien était simplement
autour des 30% et qu'il devait s'appuyer
sur des alliés qui avec 20 ou 25% de
voir avec plusieurs listes et bien
faisaient pratiquement autant que lui
d'espagne il ya une grande différence
politique entre un pari un parti par
donkey à 30% des sièges ou un parti qui
à 45 % des sièges et qui a besoin de
partenaires pour former une majorité
est-ce qu'en cas de victoire du likoud
justement à quoi doit-on s'attendre en
termes d'alliance
je crois qu'il faut il faut attendre
parce que comme on vient de le dire
étant donné le nombre de listes
possibles qui peuvent accompagner le
likoud
il n'y a pas de lapin sortir du chapeau
ce soir ah les fameux 3 25% de devoir
qui permettent d'obtenir des sièges donc
sont suffisamment bas et sont même très
bas et donc donne un jeu toujours très
très très ouvert dans les alliances
merci à vous au jard espère de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse